ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show the dave chappelle
controversy
keeps going it rolls on no matter what
else we should be talking about dave
chappelle's netflix special has become
the focal point of the media in this
country it is not the uh
rapidly rising prices of utilities of
food
it is not the massive homelessness
problem it is not the inability of uh
the government washington to function
uh it is not any of those things it is
the dave chappelle netflix special
where there are uh
employees of netflix who are angry at
this
uh staging a walkout of the special so
it is a special that i full disclosure
i've not seen all of i watched a little
bit of it
you know he's a master was it the
funniest thing in the world no
is he is he expressing an opinion held
by the vast majority of human beings
about men and women yes
um
but the ceo of netflix ted sarandos
who's greek right i believe so
interesting
so uh
because there's not a lot of successful
greek people
there's really not that's true the vast
majority of greeks are are not doing
well
but some of them are right they own
diners but there were working-class
people
and ted sarandos good for him it's john
stamos there's a few of them a couple
yeah rita wilson tom hanks his wife
it's not a huge group
so ted sarandos
greek
giannis babas greg uh defended dave
chappelle and said listen guys
um we're gonna put out things you may
not like them we don't think it's gonna
lead uh to uh
real world violence against trans people
that was basically the gist
of his uh
statement
um netflix chief
again defend chappelle special quote
content doesn't directly translate to
real world harm he said we have dave
chappelle on our platform we also have
hannah gatsby and then hannah gadsby who
we don't know where she's been she's
somewhere in australia and forcing a
lockdown i'll tell you that much where
is she she's in new zealand right
blinking
anyway hannah gatsby who's
she's atypical neurodivergent whatever
she's not always with us and when she is
with us she says some very disturbing
things and then goes back to where she
lives and that's great but she doesn't
really know what's going on she's kind
of fuzzy it just seems like she's like a
fuzzy photograph right her hair is never
quite
she's just caught of law and this is the
way it is mullen does it great
impression of her but every now and then
she gets real fired up you know when
someone insults greta thundberg or
whatever she gets real fired up when a
white guy does something bad so she
looked at ted tarando she was like [ __ ]
him and she literally said uh
she said hey ted surrounded just a quick
note to let you know that i would prefer
if you didn't drag my name into your
mess now i have to deal with even more
of the hate and anger that dave
chappelle's fans like to unleash on me
every time gabe gets 20 million dollars
to process his emotionally stunted
partial world view
um
[ __ ] you in your amoral algorithm cult
i do
what with more backbone than you what is
that word uh i can do more
s
[ __ ] shits
i can do more shits with more backbone
than you
what
but this is what i mean she's not she's
not fully with us yeah she's not fully
with us and god bless her she's a child
of god
she goes that's just a joke
i definitely didn't cross alarm because
you just told the world there isn't one
gabs gatsby captured or posted yes i
watched the whole thing leave me alone
trans is beautiful comedy is dead i
killed it those are the hashtags
it said it says here she's trans as well
i didn't know that well
i didn't either i had no i know i had no
idea
does she talk about this in the net i
don't think so i don't remember no right
i don't know
well
i want to see them
both of them hash it out
you know
who cares about any of this
comedy's dumb stop watching it stop
watching comedy specials get a life
truly stop watching comedies but stop
watching specials you have horrible
lives
you have horrible lives
people are doing so much cool [ __ ] on
this planet stop watching a [ __ ]
anybody talk for an hour
except this show
because this is different
but the others out there are wasting
your time not me never would i respect
you
stop turn it off turn it off and turn
this on
they're canceling halloween in seattle
which makes me think we're not canceling
it but there's a school in seattle
where they're banning the halloween
parade which makes you glad i own a
house in texas because you know it's
good to hedge your bets and you don't
know what's gonna happen with these
people i don't know what's gonna happen
um seattle elementary school cancels its
annual pumpkin parade because it quote
i don't even understand this
marginalizes students of color who don't
celebrate halloween
who are these students
that do not celebrate halloween i'm
truly confused
benjamin franklin day elementary school
by the way how is that still the name of
this school
benjamin franklin day elementary school
has canceled its upcoming halloween
parade because it quote marginalizes
students of color administrators claim
that a number of students especially
african-american boys do not celebrate
halloween i don't and feel excluded i've
never heard of this have you heard of
this we have our friends on the couch
i've never heard that african-american
boys do not celebrate halloween no never
heard that
i've never heard of that yes they're
muslim perhaps
i guess but i
i don't even know
are they are they what about all the
gang initiations on halloween
there's tons of gang initiations on
halloween and i think african-american
boys probably participate in that as you
white boys and many uh young men
so i hope we're not canceling that
as a school with a foundational beliefs
around equity for our students and
family see this doesn't i don't even
understand what this means here let's
get rid of the pumpkin parade event
we're getting rid of the pumpkin parade
and requesting that students do not come
to school in costumes and i think part
of it is that
certain kids don't have money for
costumes but that was always the way it
was
forever there's been a halloween parades
where
kids would show up and some of the kids
had really cool costumes some of the
kids came in with costumes their parents
made
and then there was the dirty kid
there's a kid named ryan
i don't want to say his name
he was dirty filthy
and he would come in white guy
irish kid
and he would come in filthy and his
parents would just beat him every day
and night
and they would piss on him
and he never had anything and he would
come to school and
he would always look like high but he
was never high but i think he was just
getting beaten so much and he was
malnourished she used to eat like pixie
stix and fun dip you know it was bad so
this kid ryan would come and he'd be
embarrassed because he'd be like oh it's
halloween i don't walk in
i forgot
we're like and and it was rough it was
very sad but then like the teachers
would give him like a pumpkin mask
so he could do the parade with everybody
else so this poor kid who smelled like
beer piss from a barn who was still
bloody from the parents just kicking the
[ __ ] out of him would just put on a
pumpkin mask
and walk
why if you cancel it his life's not
gonna get better
that's my point his life doesn't get
better ryan's parents don't decide to
love him they don't even know the
parade's happening they don't give a
[ __ ]
so he would be sad kind of he would be
sad i remember
we went to his house once to get smoked
cigarettes and he goes my house is kind
of messy and i was like but i hang out
at rosie's the crack house three doors
down for a minute he goes right right
i'm like i don't care we don't care but
we went in there and you could see just
cereal and bed just cigarettes like
ashtrays overflowing with cigarettes
like he had a bad life certain kids have
a bad life it's very very hard you know
and
he was the type of kid who they're
talking about like not
not you know
privileged
didn't have parents that cared
and and didn't show up with the uniform
you know i mean i'm sorry with the
halloween costume he didn't have enough
so the teachers
would like give him because they had
those little pumpkin masks they were
plastic and they would they would go on
with the one string yeah it was one
string it was not a lot
it wasn't good
but then there was like
there was a girl who was like 600 pounds
they dressed her as a princess like her
parents brought her in and she was just
like
walking around as a princess
and then like most of the kids had masks
right
cool kids have masks like freddy krueger
like [ __ ] it
yeah we're gonna kill you it's halloween
and then like the fat girl like the real
fat one her name was jenna first she'd
she'd go like this like she would just
do this every day with her head i don't
know why it might have been a thing but
she would go like this every day i know
what you mean she would just do this
every single day like this and they put
her in a princess outfit and she would
walk like this and then ryan who smelled
like piss would have his little
thing it was nice is my point it was a
nice day
and you can't ruin this it's not you
can't take this away for kids not
everybody it's insane everyone
celebrates halloween
halloween is about
eating candy
and [ __ ]
smashing
[ __ ] car windows or throwing eggs
shaving cream
vandalism
the the the the idea that you would just
vandalize things it's a beautiful idea
and these are people that are pro
vandalism they love it well where do you
think people
get the the itch
it starts with halloween they don't just
get into antifa you start with halloween
you do a few you know a couple of eggs a
little shaving cream on the stop sign
and then you you know you graduate to
you know federal banks in portland
but
i don't understand why they're taking
this away is there any reasoning for
this at all is there any reasoning they
decided to cancel the event this year
because it'd be upsetting for children
who can't afford a costume that's that's
awesome but then just buy them costumes
you cheap fox
why not buy them costumes well also they
they cite the loud noise levels and
crowds are triggering for some children
well that i agree with i don't like the
noise get rid of it
this i do agree with that i don't like
the noise at all that's a very good
point all right well we'll have to skip
it this year moving on we have a
feel-good story that's a very good point
i didn't realize that they yell and
scream it is disgusting
we have a feel-good story now coming out
of austin texas now we try to find these
stories god help us because as you know
things in the country are not good
inflation the price of a mcgriddle now
is what 38 dollars one mcgriddle 38
it's bad
and the government just keeps telling
you that if you complain about inflation
you're a nazi white supremacist and uh
the press secretary is always like what
is it i'm sorry that your gun is costing
you too much money this month you're
like well i'm kind of you know the
chicken wings are they've gone up my
family likes chicken wings
but the price of everything is going up
food and gas and the supply chains are
broken down
quote almost everything a person needs
to buy is more expensive blame the
pandemic
the supply chains have broken down
we have all kinds of chaos
now can you play the video of this woman
let's play this woman who's being
interviewed outside the grocery store
there's nothing better than when you get
a person
outside of a grocery store uh to give an
opinion quote everything has gone sky
high from groceries to gas prices
skyrocketing and could get worse
here we go
more than expected on everything from
food to housing to gas at this point it
is very hard to ignore everywhere we go
things are more expensive so how much
more can prices go up and what's causing
this rapid inflation tonight christina
rex set out to get some answers
prices are ridiculous the meat is above
and beyond
all right it's gone sky high everything
has gone sky high and it's extremely sad
have you ever been to me the me is above
and beyond
and my husband likes me
and i'm making meat and i've made a meat
for my entire life
i brown it with
butter
in a pan
and it's sky high now
we eat
six pounds of meat a week
and now i can't afford it
and
i made a salad the other day
and my husband grabbed me by the throat
and he took my head and he he mushed it
you ever mushed someone he mushed my
face he didn't hit me but he mushed me
he mushed me into the wall
and he said you better find a way to
make this work
it's sky high well this woman i mean
again
they're outside of a store called market
basket god help us
but it's sad because you know people
need uh the you know groceries and
they're too expensive now
and
you know it's very unfortunate all this
stuff is is going on and this is the the
result of a breakdown in the supply
chain
uh
there's other people saying blaming the
pandemic they're saying the simplest
explanation is everyone has been cooped
up for a year and not spending as much
as they ordinarily would and now we all
decided at the same time we wanted to go
out and spend money on things
said tony cookson co-director of the
center for research on consumer
financial decision making
quote when we all decide to do that at
the same time the issue is the economy
needs to provide us with all those goods
we don't have unlimited capacity to do
that
well then there's also the thing we have
less people working you have a lot of
people now and this is probably a good
thing in the long term they have more
leverage workers have more leverage and
they're striking now because there are
less workers and and and kellogg's you
hear about this they are striking
account now i don't know the specifics
of this i can't imagine i'm going to
side with kellogg's but the workers want
benefits they want retirement packages
they want days off and kellogg's cereal
is basically coming out and saying [ __ ]
you
we'll move the jobs to mexico
and then denying it they're saying we
didn't say that
find ben the statement from kellogg's
cereal okay
kellogg's put out a statement there's
people standing in the rain i believe
it's in omaha nebraska and they're and
they're protesting and they're saying we
want
better hours we want more money we want
better benefits and then kellogg's has a
counterpoint to all that and they put
out a video where they were just
basically like what you need to do is
keep your mouth shut
is this it right here i believe so
battle creek michigan kellogg company
today is publicly addressing the terms
of its master labor contract negotiation
with it so they're sending out chris
bonner
chris bonner
i guess is an executive
at
is that her is she an executive it says
kellogg company spokesperson this is the
person she's the spokesperson she's
gonna soften the message because the guy
you can't bring out like mr kellogg
he'll be like [ __ ] these commie [ __ ]
you can't do that
you can't do that put the hoses on them
turn the hose she's like let's talk
about building a family turn the hoses
on in my day we had dogs we took hoses
and sprayed them
so this is chris bonner she's the
spokesperson for the kellogg's
cereal company that is trying very hard
to retain the uh slave labor
we value all our employees everybody
runs their efforts first of all
first of all could anyone look
couldn't they have gotten anyone else to
do this than this karen look at this
woman
this woman
could not effectively communicate
anything they have billions of dollars
and they can't get anyone better than
her
we we value all of our employees let's
let's let's continue this especially
during this global pandemic
we are deeply concerned that the union
at our four u.s cereal plants has
decided to strike and what that means
for our employees
being away from work puts our people and
their families in a difficult position
and can create financial hardships and
pay them our number one priority is to
get back to the negotiations table and
reach a contract so our employees can
get back to their jobs and their lives
the contract that kell offered was very
fair
you were allowed to use the bathroom
twice a week
this was a fair cut this is not a bad
deal you it was a 16-hour day
with two breaks
every eight hours you would take a break
the break was supervised you would take
a supervised break
um and you would take a break which i
think is nice at your station
because when you when you go outside
they have found they've done a lot of
studies that going outside has all kinds
of effects on the worker they see the
blue sky and it get they get very
distracted and it's very triggering so
they have the break of the station
and you have the break and you stand
there silently and it's a supervised
break because they again don't want
anyone going outside or making a phone
call or calling home or doing anything
that could distract them and every eight
hours you get one of these breaks
twice a week you're allowed to leave
your station and use the restroom um for
number two number one is a catheter so
whatever you're doing as you're toasting
the uh i don't know what the hell
they're doing the special okay
as you're toasting the cornflakes
oh that's general mills kellogg's is
what corn flakes i think it's cornflakes
no it might be general mills you don't
think
find out
we're we're making we're slandering a
company let's at least slander the right
ones
here i'm on their foods and brands here
we go
kellogg's corn flakes yeah corn flakes
and all kinds of stuff so as you're
toasting the corn flakes
you get you you will use the rest you
will have a catheter meaning you will
pee and then it'll be a colostomy bag on
your leg of your of your um
you know of your uh what's the word for
piss uh urine or uh whatever i have your
urine on the leg
and it's not a big deal now in terms of
a vacation
in terms of a vacation okay
they're offering a vacation
at a kellogg's approved facility which
will be very similar to a resort okay
but you will work
during the vacation because it gives you
pride
it gives you dignity going to a resort
is undignified but going to a
specialized kellogs and where you will
work eight-hour days as opposed to 16
and you will then spend time with your
family and
they they're throwing in
uh frosted mini wheats
for the children at the at the kellogg's
themed resort it'll have a pool
it'll have
fun
history of kellogg's stuff on the walls
and frosted mini wheats for your
children
um if your children get sick from eating
corn pops or eggo waffles or any of
their products froot loops
i love how hot they have kashi like they
don't even you know
but if your kids get sick
they will allow you
an hour to take your child to the doctor
now they're not gonna pay for it but if
you can find the money to get your kid
to the doctor
you can leave the facility for one hour
at one hour and one minute you will
forfeit your pay for the week
i don't think these are bad terms let's
continue with this woman because
i think she's fair concerned that the
union struck without allowing members to
vote on the company's october 1st offer
kellogg's proposals have been grossly
misrepresented by the union in
statements to their membership and to
media and we want our employees to have
all the information they need this is
what they're doing
this is the real thing they're offering
nine percent wage increase
for legacy employees we don't even know
what that means
nine percent
pathway to full legacy rate and
significant increases for transitional
employees which means the entire company
transitional employees like everyone
right
no change to employees current
healthcare plans
enhanced
interrogation i'm kidding enhanced
retirement benefits for transitional
employees
increased pension multiplier
no proposals related to continuous crew
or alternative work schedules
one week paid time off at vacation rate
one week
not bad
one week paid time off
which you can spend going to the doctor
with your kids
because let's finish the this woman
need to make informed decisions for
themselves and their families
let's start with what we are not doing
kellogg is not asking employees to give
up health care retirement benefits or
holiday and vacation pay right the fact
is we're proud that most employees
working under this contract have
industry leading pay and benefits and
all have above market wages in
retirement the grain in fact the average
2020 earnings for the majority of our
hourly serial employees was a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars per year and
more than a third earned between 120
that's the the math the math done
to get to that yeah we're all supposed
to believe that a bunch of people making
120k a year are incensed right which is
a complex that's complete lie
she goes the average 20 20 earnings for
our hourly cal exterior employees
meaning they're averaging like five
people who've been there forever who
they actually pay
with everyone else but there's no way
that's the case there's no way that a
bunch of people are making 120 grand a
year in the kellogg's factory and
they're all striking right now
there's just such a lie can you imagine
that yeah in kansas making 120 an hour
our average our average hourly employee
earns 5 million a year
we have industry leading pay
that can't be true
eight thousand and two hundred thousand
most also have unparalleled no cost
comprehensive health insurance meaning
they pay nothing for their health care
no premiums no deductibles nothing
less senior employees have the same
health insurance plan that all our
salaried employees have except they pay
much lower employee contributions than
the rest of us a construct that i would
light upon
so why are they doing this are they
sociopaths
what are they doing why are they doing
it have they lost their minds
i don't you know right
what what are they doing
free health care 120 grand a year sounds
great right what are you talking about
let's go to the can we get a kellogg
employee
who's probably just going to be full of
scabs and bleeding yeah let's find an
employee just some vietnam veterans
sitting there in a wheelchair
just [ __ ] bleeding
screaming about rice krispie treats one
of them has to be on youtube right
there's got to be a kellogg employee
explaining what's going on we got you
know unless kellogg's try yeah oh here
we go here we go
well this morning kellogg is no longer
making cereal workers have voted to
strike last night this strike went into
effect at midnight after the union's
five-year contract with the company
expired news 8's dana white is live
outside the battle creek kellogg
facility now with a deeper look into
this dispute
emily donovan good morning members of
the union voted on this strike yesterday
after negotiations between them and
kellogg went through you can see that we
have buses of employees coming here this
morning and the members of the strike
are not letting up the contract for all
facilities expired at midnight and there
is no new one in place according to the
union's website there are still some
issues to resolve in the most recent
offer from kellogg including the
elimination of cost of living
adjustments the creation of permanent
transitional positions no full-time
benefits for those permanent workers and
adjusted to the pto policy a holiday pay
change and a plan to remove all union
logos from products we spoke with one of
the strike leaders this morning
everybody in this plant makes
incredible sacrifices that most people
wouldn't understand they work
eight days a week at least
and that's months on end without a
scheduled day off i mean some some
people in the plant
don't have a scheduled day off for the
entire year
um so we're not willing to accept that
anymore
union leaders also allege that the most
recent contract proposal was never
presented to the negotiating committee
they say their committee is still at the
table and that kellogg sent home its
negotiators before posting the current
offer we reached out to kellogg
no cereal
because these people want to see their
kids
how lazy are these people
what's gonna happen if someone wants
cereal
is everyone does do people not
understand
morality and what's morally right and
what's morally wrong
it is not right to strike and deprive
people
of frosted mini-wheats because you
think you need to go and see your
children for a day
so there's a guy standing in a storm
and this has gone viral image of
kellogg's worker picketing and 3 a.m
storm goes viral well this these are the
things i don't this is like when you
find a kid you know the drone strike
they show the kid and the drone strike
and they go this is why we have to fight
isis because and you go what
um
i do like the tony the tiger i'm greedy
sign it is fun because you know what you
can do here with the strike and people
lose you can have a lot of fun with the
mascots you can have a lot of fun with
the mascot like there should be a mini
wheat with the the hammer and sickle
you know the communist hammer and sickle
there should be a mini wheat
doing that
dress up a mini wheat is joseph stalin
if they're not dressing up mini wheats
as joseph stalin
the rice crispy
what are they elves
the rice crispy elves should be
uh
they should be painted
killing executives
like cutting the throats of executives
the froot loops toucan toucan sam
toucan sam
should have his arm around mao zedong
this is fun
this is good this gets people thinking
because you start going oh this is
interesting even the mascots are getting
involved a lot of the problem is i don't
care about any of those people right you
know the people with the signs who gives
a [ __ ] i don't know them but if all the
mascots got together the sun tony the
tiger those twinks who make rice crispy
treats uh and the corn flakes uh chicken
if they are a rooster he's a rooster
whatever his gender is none of my
business if they all got together and
explicitly if there was artwork of them
killing executives burning their houses
down
you know that to me would be a little
exciting i'd want to get more on board
yes
you know get a picture of joseph stalin
get a picture of stalin up now let's
imagine
get a get a nice picture okay of of uh
stalin i like this one this one's good
make that make give the raisin bran sun
put the raisin bran sun as stalin
i that's my point better help people are
sad
people are tense they're anxious the
world is opening up again and there's a
lot of people that live in
therapy deserts that's like food deserts
meaning you can't get good one-on-one
therapy
so what do you do you go online and you
talk to a licensed professional in under
48 hours with better health if you don't
like that counselor you move on to
another one who gives a [ __ ] you are in
the driver's seat it better help
they have so many great counselors that
care about you this isn't a crisis line
this is real deal
therapy
it helps people help and it's better
than other options
if you're feeling sad
or mad
or bad
go to better help
if you're feeling
upset
or bereft
go to better help
if you're feeling tense if you're on the
fence
go to bed or help
if you want to be a dancer or if you
have late stage cancer
go to bed or
help if
your pet has been dead a while or you're
a pedophile
coda better help if you if they edit
this out i will fire you
better
no you you got to leave this in man okay
all right
do they want the business or not
truly go to betterhelp.com timd that's
betterhlp.comd there's over 1 million
people who've taken charge of their
mental health with all the help of
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help
they're recruiting counselors in all 50
states the podcast is sponsored by
better help and timberland show
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.comd
sheath underwear i love sheath underwear
the the owner of it used to uh was in
the military in the iraq war go to
sheath underwear.com you get underwear
that is so comfortable
you'll never want to wear another type
of underwear it has a package for your
balls and your junk and
this and and i support
trans businesses this guy was a woman
when he served in the iraq war robert
patron was a woman and i'm not dead
naming him he likes this because it's
inspiring he was a woman named sheila
sheila patron and he
got
um
surgery transgender surgery in iraq
how [ __ ] cool is that awesome [ __ ]
awesome and then he became a one of the
first
trans people to shoot a 12 year old in
the head
sheath underwear dot com
do some [ __ ] research they love
comedy and they support the show
you're supporting a trans
murderer
trans murdering business
go to bed she's underwear duck what does
that even mean oh sheath underwear dot
com use promo code tim to save 20
percent sheath underwear dot com use
code tim to save 20
feel good story today coming out of
austin texas austin texas as you know uh
a place where i live
it is a beautiful place
it is the epicenter of comedy in america
it's
there's nothing
funnier than austin texas there's
nothing funnier when you land there
it is funny i mean you laugh
from when your feet leave the plane to
when you walk back on the plane it's
funny i mean it's just
hilarious it's
even the shootings and there's many of
them are funny
even the people that attack you in the
street it's funny they they do it in a
funny way
it's funny
how you get uh carjacked it's funny it's
fun
and every now and then because so much
of the news is sad so much of the news
is sad
the kellogg's company going to war with
the people that make cereal i didn't
even know you needed to
i thought cereal just kind of happened
but apparently there's people doing it
it's crazy
um
so this is a this is just a feel-good
story this is a light
fun story sometimes we do things on the
show that have a dark there's a darkness
to them this is not that this is light
fluffy fun
and and and
it's beautiful i want you to watch this
because it is truly
it it's just a great story about
human beings and just having fun
and doing good stuff
this is body cam video from star flight
senior flight nurse jennifer roberts
among those she rescued thursday from a
swollen blanco river in san marcos was
frank fell she was
so in control that i just felt it was
relaxing to know they were there because
up until that point we were pretty sure
we weren't going to make it friday i
showed roberts what frank had to say
it means a lot we often don't get to
meet anybody after the fact or hear how
people do or or anything and so it's
really nice to hear those hear those
comments
the call for starflight to head to san
marcos came after storm waters rushed
down the blanco river and into transient
campsites there this is beautiful
the rivers are now biblically
washing the homeless down the river in
austin the homeless that live on the
riverbed are being washed away
by uh the rivers
and they're they're
their homes are being washed down the
rivers and
don't think too much about that that's
not what the story's about the story is
about this uh these first responders who
then rescued
one of the people frank fell frank
i don't know what happened to the others
i'm i'm sure they are fine
one of the homeless people one or two of
them were rescued so we're focusing on
that we're just kind of
we don't want to get into we don't know
what happened
to the rest of them but there was a
transient community of uh homeless
people but we're saying transient and
this is
it's just another example of of of that
we're just
we're absolutely living in hell this is
the idea of a feel-good story that the
river is washing away the homeless
and that first responders ended up
saving one of them
and this is a great occasion for all of
us we should all rejoice
that uh a first responder went and saved
a homeless guy who was living down by
the riverbed
here let let's finish this
pushed into the muddy riverbank it
stopped raining and
we thought it was over and the next
thing we knew we heard we heard the
noise that we didn't know what it was
and we looked out it was just a wall of
water coming when the helicopter arrived
the crew quickly realized this was not
going to be a typical rescue mission we
knew there were four people that's about
all the information that we had
for people that need to be rescued when
we got overhead it was it was apparent
that not only were there four people but
there was also four people with
some belongings that
were clearly very important to them and
a dog and then when i got down there i
found out there was also a puppy
involved this is that puppy alive and
well
[ __ ] yeah
we're killing it
austin texas austin texas how [ __ ]
cool is that
come live by the river bring your pop
and it's gonna work out because this
[ __ ] may save you
it just it feels good i like
when things feel good
and this just makes me
happy
it makes me happy
now
i don't want to ruin i don't want to
ruin this by asking what happens to
the people now
do they go work at the kellogg's factory
what happens to these people
uh they were uh returned to a new camp
under the highway 80 bridge
well that's well that's a happy ending
that's a happy ending so you're telling
me the people they rescued went back
under the bridge what it says
well this is good this is beautiful
i was thinking it was going to be
something heartless but they're back
right under the bridge which is if you
remember
where this all started
now so they what do you do you think
they give them a shower or anything or
not really
they probably give them my new tent
right
and and then they put them back under
the bridge that's what saying here it's
saying they returned under the bridge
and uh
the the these were all smashed and
scattered into a muddy river bank
i know it's like what are you gonna do
with them i mean that's the real issue
i'm not i can't take them in
but this is the question
i i hope that but this is just gonna
keep happening it seems like it's not a
great solution
to just put them back under the bridge
but what do i know
but this is a feel-good story
this is what i mean
about the feel good stories
they're not going to be like they were
in the old days
no you know
no you're not going to have that
this isn't a story about a guy who beat
cancer
this is a story about people that were
living under a bridge
that were saved from a flood that have
then gone back to live under the bridge
that's the story and they're happy the
guy's going thank god we didn't know we
were going to make it very thankful yeah
he goes we we
we thought we weren't gonna make it but
thank god
that we were saved and are now being
deposited
back under the bridge
and then hopefully
it was a team effort according to
roberts who added
after they returned to austin they had
only one quick moment to reflect on the
rescue that's because the next call for
help could be a moment away um
well good for her
good for her this is a
this is a great system
i think
because it gets everyone can be a hero
yeah she can be a hero it's important
you need heroes and you need people to
uh
rescue people
where is that thing you sent me about
the austin crime there's just often
after like what is it after 8 p.m in
austin it just turns into a rape-a-thon
it seems to be a new segment they're
doing called like austin after hours yes
like austin after dark and that doesn't
mean like hear the fiddle player
it means just straight up like the
streets will run with blood
i had no idea how dangerous austin texas
was
it's like insanely dangerous
after 9 00 pm the streets in austin run
with blood
hold on i think our internet went down
oh god damn it the internet went down at
the temporary studio
how's it coming with our new studio by
the way
how's the new studio coming with our
with our idiot realtor
hey guys my wife's having a baby hey who
gives a [ __ ]
no one cares this big dumb idiot
because our business manager who is um
i want to be respectful but he's
mentally [ __ ]
he
every friend he has or connection he has
is a bigger loser than him amazingly
so he sets this up with this like frat
boy
[ __ ] who's like
my wife's having a baby
he shows us a unit
like i'm not saying you have to know who
i am but like google me if you have a
client i'm like yeah my new building
there's a lot of these [ __ ] running
around he's like are you single that
could be pretty good
yeah
it's like all right buddy will you calm
it down we're not playing beer pong here
okay but again it's this frat boy kind
of jovial horseshit that you know so we
go we go to a unit with this guy right
that's correct yeah and then we find out
we say we'll take it and then what does
he say he says it's not available that's
right
so he's wasting our time he's wasting
his time
now do you realize how low on the totem
pole you have to be to be showing office
space in la
i mean this is the single this is the
capital the single family home if you
want to make some [ __ ] money you go
sling some bedrooms and bathrooms you
but this guy is showing office space
there there's a no one even wants to go
back into the office anymore and he's
showing office space
and he was recommended by our business
manager
i mean
i just don't understand
i'm i'm losing my patience we're trying
to get a real studio am i wrong no
you're right to lose my patience no we
thought we had the studio we thought we
had it i'm sorry should i not be talking
about this publicly
i'm not mentioning his name but the slob
who manages our money has got to stop
connecting us with his near-duel
deadbeat friends
it's not my fault that everyone you know
is the lowest person in every industry
can you [ __ ] please get one decent
connection that you can hook us up with
i mean christ almighty
i mean it's like enough already and him
i got to get on you because you're so
sweet i always have to be the bad guy
because these people you you're like hey
i gotta call up like a big fat [ __ ] and
scream to get something done
here's the austin after hours police
watching late night clubs so this is
like again if you're gonna have a
bachelorette party go down to austin
this is the place
you're gonna love it you fat
bachelorette don't go to nashville come
down here this is what's waiting for you
in austin i will not rest until the city
of austin is condemned
austin after hours patrolling
entertainment district has seen more
violent crime in the last several months
to learn more about what's driving it
our team went out this past weekend with
apd's downtown patrol officers and they
tell kxa and investigator kevin clark
they're getting more calls after the bar
is closed everybody's realizing how long
this is why there's violent crime people
are realizing how bad it is and they're
angry and they can't kill elon musk so
they have to kill who's ever in their
vicinity they've all been sold this bill
of goods they go down there and they're
like
it's not even fun
it isn't fun
and they're just all drugged up
and they've got a loaded gun on them
because it's america right and they just
start [ __ ] going crazy
let's continue this
gunshot wound
and at 1 18 saturday morning sergeant
garabay started running
kxan investigators right behind one
victim
three blocks from the heart of the sixth
street entertainment district
we got a bachelor party where thousands
were gathered was a 17 year old in
critical condition he later died at the
hospital let me get some crime scene
tape it out police say it came after a
gun battle between two groups which
prompted an officer to fire their own
weapon it's a crime scene sir
thank you for sergeant garabay and other
downtown patrols the night can change in
an instant two hours earlier he told me
this based on the crowd right now i
think we're gonna have a happy crowd
with a few disturbances
that's my
my forecast for tonight we initially
came out with police because of their
concern over after hours clubs one of
them we told you about is tellers which
police described as the site of violent
offenses from assaults robberies and
even shootings apd has written 47 crime
reports tied to the trinity street
address so far in 2021 more than the
previous three years combined that was a
bar that typically generated a lot of
calls for us after bar hours
a lot of disturbances you know that took
place in front of the bar well whatever
temporary i'm not i'm not trying to i
don't care about after-hours stuff i'm
not trying to get somebody in trouble
here what i'm trying to say is that this
city
is
just
always on the brink
it's always on the brink of exploding
in gunfire
every night
i mean
god we got hood winked
how do we get hoodwinked like this
you're supposed to look out for me and
you don't i let you down you let me down
big time you should have told me you got
excited to go back to texas a little bit
yeah you did because because
people like you
down deep
you know it's your culture it's not my
culture
you know yeah it's not my culture
it's your culture you know
i'm not you know like i appreciate all
the cultural experiences i mean you had
cops at your wedding
you would police at your wedding
sheriffs you had sheriffs at the wedding
making sure people didn't drink too much
that's not my culture
it's not my culture there's nothing
wrong with it
i'm happy i enjoyed your wedding it was
very nice thank you it was very sweet
thank you but
this is just a different way of life
for me
and for a lot of uh
people that we know but you you know
there's something about you that you you
you also
uh
realize that this is you know
this is not good
you must you must leave
it's horrible it's horrible it's
terrible you know
you you have to not do this
you know
and i know that people
people like you
see a value in it
because you're animals
but i you know what i mean well part of
you wants to go back to long island part
of me wanted to go back to texas that's
right um
but long island is a beautiful place of
amazing people
that's the difference
do you understand the difference
there's a huge difference between me
wanting to do that
and you wanting
you know
at your wedding a woman gave birth
a woman gave birth
your sister gave birth at your wedding
and
it made
it made people me it made me
uncomfortable i'm sorry and no one cared
[Laughter]
and the baby
came out
bloody
full of after birth and it just started
eating a rib
it's not right
it's a weird life
that's all i'm saying
it's strange
and you made us move there
because you're listening to joe rogan
i had no part in this
you said it's gonna be good for your
comedy career
to move down there
that's why you made us move
you said i'm gonna do comedy at joe
rogan's new club that's right
yeah
i just dragged you kicking and screaming
the whole way wouldn't it be funny if
you opened the club called vaccines
that would be funny
it was just called vaccines
you know
that would be fun
i'd work there
ship station online is everything right
now you know it and i know it
if you have an online business but you
don't know about the shipping you got to
try ship station they funnel all your
orders into one simple interface that
you can manage from anywhere even your
cell phone
you shouldn't be worrying about the back
office stuff
you need to be spending time generating
business shipstation has access to all
the major carriers ups fedex usps easily
compare characters and choose the best
solution every time ship stations small
businesses can now access the same rates
usually reserved for fortune 500
companies without the contracts or
commitments just use my offer called tim
dillon to get a 60-day free trial that's
t-i-m-t-i-l-o-n tim dillon to get a
60-day free trial that's two months free
of no hassle stress free shipping just
go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
type in tim dillon that shipstation.com
enter offer code tim dillon i'm telling
you right now guys if you want to free
yourself up to work on whatever it is
the art or the generating of the
business the sales to marketing and you
don't want to worry at all about
shipping you got to use ship station
make ship happen
i love raycon earbuds they're so much
better than all the [ __ ] that you
get from apple raycon is amazing they
look and feel and sound better than ever
raycon is great they're cheaper but
better
six hours of non-stop play time they
have pure mode balance mode bass mode
you can you can listen to music any way
you want they have noise cancelling but
they also have a feature where you can
also hear noise if you want to to make
sure that you stay alert raycon started
half the price of other premium audio
brands but they just sound they sound
just as good they sound better
rate guns come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee if anything happens they'll
replace it right now listeners can get
15 off their raycon order at
buyracon.com that's by raycon dot com
tim to say 15
these are great headphones they're
better than everything else
i have raycon earphones and i use them
and if i have extra ones i eat them
they're also good as a snack
but i like to listen to them i put them
in my ears and i listen to people sing
steve will do it we can't say enough
great things about steve steve is a
philanthropist along with his friend
takashi69
they go around and help people
steve does give people money
steve from nelk we all know nelk it's
the group
of pranksters that run around the
country going to colleges telling people
to have fun and party and drink and jump
off roofs and
be cool
the milk boys
steve is the breakout star of the nilk
boys check out his happy dad cells are
available in stores in florida nevada
california and massachusetts not the
brightest states
but that's where they're marketing the
happy dad in states where people party
right
florida nevada california and
massachusetts they're not 50 states yet
but they're starting with the states
where people
are most likely to uh become paralyzed
after a night out
steve is one of the most emer he's the
biggest emerging one of the biggest
emerging fashion brands with full send
go to fullsend.com sign up for exclusive
merch drops everything is currently sold
out and if you don't want to miss it you
got to go to fullsend.com
so what steve does is he sends people
money because he makes money gambling or
bitcoin or something
he does something in
what does he do it's a i think it's a
gambling website he does something in
mexico yeah yeah
i mean i don't think we can talk about
that part of that what does he do he
tests people for aids down there
i think he has aids tests in mexico
it's like the theranos elizabeth holmes
right is that what he's doing i think so
yeah well he's whatever he's doing he
he's donating money he gives money some
people say i need money he gives him
money and don't get any ideas people
with me but he'll send him like 600 on
them he's a good person he's a good guy
yes he like he drinks he'll drink a fish
tank of booze and then grab takashi six
nine and then gore they just walk into a
cancer ward and make it rain
they just make it rain
in a cancer world all those little bald
kids with the full scent hoodies
and he's just good like that
he's good like that he gave david dobrik
a tesla and david dobrik is an
underprivileged guy
right that's right because he's at a
rough time remember because he tried to
kill his friend
now and there's nothing wrong with that
i'm not mad at him for that who cares
you you you you you you threw your
friend off what do you put him on a
parachute or something and whatever the
guy hit the water at the wrong angle he
thought he was dead shut up everyone's a
puss
so we'll do it gave david dobrik uh a
tesla
because uh it's nice
i thought it was a rape thing
well no that was
that was before that okay gotcha and
you know i don't know what's going on
here david dobrik is never accused of
that
he's never accused of doing anything
wrong
see when you say things like that that's
legally actionable that's why you don't
speak
some other guy part of his crew might
have been at something right right but
i'm not i'm not a let's blame everybody
for everybody no no no no i'm not into
that i have no issues
uh with uh uh uh david dobrik and well i
don't know anything about them i don't i
i like entertainment and if a few people
get paralyzed
for entertainment
not a big deal for me
go to steve we'll do its youtube channel
right now and see what all the hubbub is
about for yourself steve drops new
videos every single thursday he loves
cigarettes but then he quits and he goes
back
so go there steve will do it
his youtube channel that's s t e v e w i
l
o
you got to spell it out steve will do it
on youtube
um
i think these now kids are really
helping out
because
they are are teaching
young people
that life is about
getting drunk
and using drugs and having sex and
partying
and i think we've gone so far away
we we've we've gotten we've gone so far
into that other
thing
where everybody's thinking and they're
so annoying there's something really
beautiful about
the nelk brand of how to live your life
milk is a way to live your life
it's a way to live your life now you
have to stop
doing that eventually
because you're gonna die right you're
gonna die yeah
but the good news is
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah you're gonna die
so steve will do it llc we love him he's
a fan of the show we've never met him
we had one dinner with these people and
he chose not to show up but that's okay
i don't know what he was doing
brushing his teeth or something i don't
know but he didn't come
and uh
but it's fun it's a they're a great
group
i'm a fan
of the uh
nelk
philosophy on life
which is like hey who cares where your
shoe is
it doesn't matter that you're failing
that's their philosophy
who cares about your shoe your mother's
a stupid [ __ ]
what was she gonna do with that money
anyway
she's spending the money on your college
but what was that dumb [ __ ] gonna do
with it
who cares
your academic advisor can go [ __ ]
himself that guy's a loser
he keeps running his [ __ ] mouth maybe
he'll just beat his ass
beat his ass bro
break your academic advisor's neck
if he tells you to use it and [ __ ] your
doctor to this [ __ ] [ __ ]
who tells you that you have cancer of
the liver now it doesn't matter
sometimes people throw up blood it's
part of life
you know
and i think that's a decent philosophy
on life
[ __ ] your mom
[ __ ] the cops
you can handle it
seven beers deep you can handle driving
to another bar
it's not a big deal
you understand yeah they're very
forgiving of of people's past there it's
it's old school christianity yes really
yeah yeah
that's what i think of when i think of
nalc
like an old school
christianity
i talk to guys in college sometimes
because i want to have sex with them and
all of them they always say to me like
get me facetime me with steve will do it
that's their they all they want that's
all they want is to talk to steve will
do it that's literally all they want to
do that's your entire life
it's amazing he's a cool guy he's a very
cool guy we haven't met up
hopefully we'll meet him
um go to his steve will do it on youtube
we're not doing the smiley face killer
episode we went to interview one of
these uh people
uh an academic about the smiley face
killer
he was mentally unwell
and it we're not putting the episode out
because maybe these kids are getting
thrown into rivers they probably are but
god help them the people that are trying
to
figure out what's going on are been
trying since 2006 and they're all frauds
and this guy was mentally ill
he said do you want to speak to my
girlfriend she has a gift of prophecy we
went all the way to [ __ ] some [ __ ]
horrible town
ugh
so we're not putting the episode out
yeah
we're not putting it out yeah big waste
of time it was a huge waste of time
which again
you did
you got to vet these people
you have to vet them
we tried
should we play a minute of it for
everyone i mean i haven't mixed the
episode i think i have it somewhere let
me see play a minute of this mental
patient
that we had to suffer through i got it
on my external let me grab it hold on we
we we we we go there and the guy's
confused he's out of it
the smiley face killer theory is these
young
athletic college-aged males end up in
the river
some of it maybe they fell in but a lot
but they think it's some cult or
something so we go down there to
interview this old guy and he like kind
of confesses to it
he like literally said i predict where
they're gonna be and i make sure i go to
the atm and get money out so they don't
think i'm doing it every three hours
what the [ __ ] this
so let's play a minute or two of this so
you could see how crazy he is
so that
you know you can understand why we can't
put this out we're trying to do a fun
halloween episode
okay so i have his audio so let me let's
just play his audio i haven't mixed the
episode yeah just go to the middle of it
or something okay here we go
after about
45 minutes i said
you know people who are unemployed or
in and out of work
retired it seems to be
just like any other call you guys ever
spoken to somebody who is a member of
the group or an ex-member of the group
or anything like that
uh we have and uh
uh of course we've certainly protected
their identity
okay but they haven't
in the past uh there's you've spoken to
an actual ex-member of the group that's
carrying these things out
yeah
okay yes we have guys he's not this guy
yeah yeah
should i skip around one more time yeah
that stood out to me especially as it
started to spread out
across the united states
if i were to take the profile and and
you can go online just pick any one of
these young men he starts going into
facebook now and it i can't do we can't
even i can't even deal with it
but we flew there to interview this guy
that's been working on this case since
2006. we go do you have any motive and
he goes we're not releasing the motive
and i go why are you not releasing the
motive he goes well then there'll be
copycat killings and i'm like well
there's already copycat killings and
what do you mean the motive dummy
nobody's gonna copy the [ __ ] motive
so he he refused to talk about the
motive he
right he's the guy was a sweet man but
he's senile he didn't want to give away
the symbols
the motive you the whole thing's the
smiley face killer
you gave away the symbol
but i think it's these detectives that
like they fill these families with hope
and then
because there are shady these drownings
are shady you know these don't make any
sense so these like goons
from new york the detectives they're
like hey your son ended up in the water
i'm gonna solve the case
i'm gonna solve the case i'm doing a lot
of work i need money
can you give me money
and then i'll i'll make all the bad
people pay and then the families like
give these dirt bags money
and then they just like these dirtbag
detectives buy chinese food with it
and they did a show on the oxygen
network
where they're exploiting the deaths of
these people they have absolutely no
leads they have nothing going on
and instead of like investigating it
they're just like eating egg rolls in
new york we do anything can you play
them please play can we play the oxygen
network trailer yeah absolutely play the
trailer for additional materials this
hunk of [ __ ] that oxygen network did
uh with these three goons
claiming that they know about the smiley
face killers oh not the best red east
and alice also just did a horrible movie
about the smiley face killers because
that guy is the smiley face killer
remember when he wanted us on the pot
like he said to me like i was like can
you do my podcast he goes no but you can
do mine
remember that yeah he kind of big time
and he had like 3 000 patrons and we
thought that was huge yeah yeah [ __ ] you
american psycho is good but after that
it's been a lot of [ __ ]
what is the what what is your patreon
you talk about laurel canyon with
lindsay lohan cut it out
we've had enough
had enough of him next
this is the uh the trailer for the uh
fake show on oxygen where these three
detectives go around pretending they
know who the smiley face killer is and
it's it's like teresa caputo
the long island uh medium who's
pretending that she knows that dead i
mean it's so heinous what they're doing
to these parents they're like we got all
these leads we're gonna make it right
we're gonna do and they don't have [ __ ]
let's watch this couldn't
get to him fast enough it's hard to
think about somebody hurting your child
but i think someone hurt him it's like
it happened yesterday for me
but just
just rip your heart out
hundreds of years he's so sad
he's very sad parents yeah okay it's
tragic and there's really shady
circumstances with these drownings enter
through the goon squad
from new york watch this
i'm drowned in clusters around the
country we've been investigating for the
last 12 years
heading home and heading that direction
the 50 million dollar question is how
did he get in the water this is where
the dogs lost the saint they lost cod
scent
right here pavement
all classified as accidental or
undetermined when the numbers start to
add and you just you see it something's
not right so there is a pattern that's
been growing it doesn't make any sense
to me he was a champion swimmer in high
school nobody believes it was an
accident nobody these retired nypd
detectives aren't buying it all we know
right now is that dakota james did not
drown accidentally i can't tell you what
happened to luke but i can tell you what
didn't happen to luke in almost all the
cases we have found smiley face machine
near the body recovery center
the smelly face graffiti links lr cases
the search for truth he's got defensive
wounds an offensive wound from blocking
and striking he had to have been
deceased from the drugs prior to
entering the water
could reopen hundreds of cases
this is a highly suspicious case smiley
face three stars three victims recovered
and bring justice to these families this
is what the family wants they want a
true investigation i believe that luke
was murdered i mean i know i can't bring
my son back but i just really wanted
justice for him he was never going to
come in and he was my own
here's the thing i'm not saying these
kids aren't being murdered
i mean what i'm saying is that these
detectives have been working on this
case since 2006 they have nothing
they have there's not a suspect there's
nothing they have nothing except a tv
show that's not the goal when you
investigate a case is to get a tv show
like [ __ ] 10 years later to 15 years
later the goal is to solve the crime
well i think they wrote a book yeah they
wrote a book and they got a tv show they
got a real great career
solve the [ __ ] crime and they can't
do it
and you have these poor parents that are
now sick of these detectives they're
like because they're like hey i got a
lead
you know and that voice one of them's
being banged up for sexual assault or
whatever
i don't know but the oxygen network i
think parted ways with these three
goons they said get out of here tell it
walking because the detectives are from
new york they're like i'm a new york
detective i'm in new york the time i'm
gonna figure out
i'm gonna figure it out i don't know
anything
i don't know anything about how your son
died but i'm here to bother you
and to get on tv
have you heard of television
we're going to be on tv together
you had a horrible tragedy i have no
career
those two things are beautiful
you look at the camera and cry
and i'm gonna present myself as a guy
helping you when all i'm doing is
wasting everybody's time
they went on like dr phil
it's just
it's just not right to do right
it's not right to do
it would be like if i kept showing up
to like
like
someone if i was looking up like missing
kids
and i kept showing up to their parents
houses and telling them that i had an
idea of how it happened
and i'm like i got a podcast
we're gonna figure it out right
if i kept showing up do you have any
leads i go no but i think something
shady happened they go yeah
we'll figure it out
let me get my goon squad can you get the
first episode up where these [ __ ]
idiots are eating bacon egg and cheeses
remember they're eating in a diner it's
the first episode
yeah they're eating some greasy spoon
diner it's a real [ __ ] a food network
special see if they have him up here
these parents are crying so then they
bring in the hollywood medium who's not
the long island medium he's the gay
hollywood medium and then he like talks
to one of the parents like
it's so
heinous what they are doing to these
parents
i don't think it's this clip let me see
maybe it's this one
no it's the first one it's like the
first thing in the series
sitting there and they're eating like
sausage and you're like hey
[ __ ] the smiley face killer
there's the smile
and i'm all for believing these people
end up in the river in a very suspect
way
and i'm not just all the things we
figured out on this show are not figured
out but you know that we just know in
general epstein and johnny gosh and all
that stuff i'm not dismissing
the idea that these kids are meeting
their end
uh
you know
in a way where you do have
but
this is the beginning by the way
can you imagine if your son died in a
river
your son is dead not someone like me or
my parents want that but like a young
hot college guy with a thick [ __ ] that
you see even as his parent you don't
want to [ __ ] him but you're like look at
that [ __ ] you know
and and imagine your child has been
murdered
he's dead
these three sausage and pepper heroes
show up to your house
and they're
they tell you there's a tv show
about it and now you're gonna you're
gonna crack the case wide open so you've
got your dead child your life is ruined
justice is in the hands of these [ __ ]
meatballs
this is
scene one in the tv show i would throw
them in the river
you know the food has got to be good
that's right
it's a real greasy spoon it's a big
winner
you're talking about food yeah
okay doctor thank you
what we have here is the new case
my beautiful boy is dead
why are you showing eggs
christ
and otherwise we wouldn't be here i
wouldn't even attract you guys out for
this
i thought there was something going on i
have prepared some stuff for
uh
ready for it my name is lee gilbertson
i'm a professor i teach criminal justice
i love puzzles he's a good guy
he had a um what a hat on a desert store
mat but he was mentally unwell
what do you want me to say though he's a
sweetheart very sweet man
sweet guy thank you no we love you
ladies he sent me a whole email he wants
me to talk to his girlfriend i can't be
involved
i mean can you imagine it's like
i mean
if there are people throwing people in a
river by the way they are going to keep
doing it i'll tell you this if the
smiley face killer is real they are fine
and they are i mean
not even a small hiccup in anything
they're doing because the brain trusts
assembled to fight them is amazing
but
mostly it's the injustice that these
families are experiencing really pisses
me off are you guys
what do you think you think
that he's one of ours dakota i'm mike
donovan i'm a retired nypd detective
when kevin asked me to come on board
with a smiley face kills investigation
homicide has not looked at this case i'm
anthony duarte a retired detective from
the bronx i'm devoting my retirement to
working on the smiling face cases these
kids are not just falling in rivers and
drowning
i believe there's a lot more sinister
activity going on
all right let's get out of this but but
christ almighty
like
even jeffrey epstein got arrested
[Laughter]
i mean it's that's really all that needs
to be said [ __ ] epstein got arrested
you can arrest one of these [ __ ]
people throwing someone in a river
i think some of these are legitimate
instances of bad stuff happening some of
them aren't they're all mixing them all
together it's a big mishmash and you got
a bunch of people that want to get on tv
not good
timberlandcomedy.com for all live dates
spokane seattle portland indianapolis
morgantown pittsburgh washington new
york
atlantic city rochester iowa city
madison wisconsin louisville kentucky
los angeles california are you guys
going to come to that la on the 26th at
the wilton
we should make them pay uh a scalper fee
which no one pays calpers
bakersfield california that'll be fun
huh
san diego can you buy the tickets and
bakers please don't make me go there
with san diego reading atlanta atlanta
st louis sacramento san fran garden city
idaho toronto ontario
ontario toronto it's a 3000 seat theater
we're selling it well it's new year's
eve it's gonna be [ __ ] crazy
it's gonna be crazy
so we're really excited about this tour
it's gonna be fun i'm doing an hour
material that i'm probably gonna tape
sometime in january and we'll we'll uh
see if we can put it out somewhere
but
it's a lot of fun
tim
dilloncomedy.com for tickets
tim j dillinger lloyd on instagram and
twitter if you want to follow us there
at ben avery is good
on twitter and instagram
we have a new studio i mean what is the
progress why don't you answer the people
that are [ __ ] sick of this [ __ ] we're
in this goddamn tick tock studio with
these [ __ ] 15 year olds come in here
and they're like every other podcast
records out here it's people being like
yeah
like the other night bro
yeah it's like where is the smiley face
killer i'm gonna call them i'll pay for
your flight
so we're sitting here in this studio
we're unfortunately back to step one
after a month of progress yeah step one
which is finding a another realtor
that's right yeah we're not even at
finding a studio we're finding it
uh
because i got all plans i got a whole
thing i want built we got a whole nice
thing here i know i know
if you and your wife would spend less
time [ __ ] around in texas
and more time getting it done
[Music]
what are the ads where are the ads you
ready to go to nats okay let's go to ads
no let's not do the ads i don't know
what do you what do you want to do you
want to eat